on the mount for the halos with the
record of one three and a four point
five seven era is the right-hander
griffin canning
two outs and that will bring up
christian walker today's d.h
and down he goes chase the break ebola
kind of a an excuse me swing there
walker was caught in between and he is a
strikeout victim and that'll win the
inning on the mound for the diamondbacks
with a record of two and three in a 4.42
era left-hander alex
young
and the angels in business here runners
on the corners with nobody out for trout
in the first inning like a one for four
game had a double and a walk last night
that has pulled off the end of the bat
out to peralta he has to come sprinting
in his throw is going to come into the
infield but fletcher is going to score
easily angels have a one-nothing lead
trout is able to pick up his 41st rbi
so here is anthony rendon ready to bet
that's drilled out to center field
marshall's got to go back on it to the
wall and now it's gone big fly for
anthony rendon as marshall bangs into
the wall
just got over the wall dead center
that's a home run that was a line drive
homer off the bat right there or rendon
a two run shot it's three nothing angels
anthony rendon home run center field
ninth of the season
two outs now for ahmed nick's been
swinging a hot bat last night he was on
base couple of times
counting looks at second delivers and
that is a high fastball he got him to
chase it struck him out and that's how
the inning will end three strikeouts for
counting against the first seven that
he's faced bases are going to be loaded
for
their hottest hitter in the lineup jared
walsh
in the air left center peralta david's
got it
ward will tag up and score the fourth
angel run but david peralta turned in a
defensive gem right there
so here is mike trout he's had a sac fly
in the game
2-1 delivery he pops this one in the air
very shallow right field coming in his
cole calhoun he's not going to get to it
it's going to drop in that's going to
drive in a run angels have runners at
the corners bloop rbi hit for trout and
now it's five to nothing angels
so the batter now is random
here's the o2 pitch
and that's a swinging strike three yeah
he's out
brendon knew it he was walking back to
the dugout before they even made the
call
side retired but two score in the inning
the batter
is anthony ben boom a strikeout victim
first time up
bamboo lofts one out to center barnshow
is there
tagging his pujols the throws coming
home
and it's going to cut off a sac fly it's
the third of the game for the angels
bamboo picks up his fourth rbi six
nothing
two out snout
and here's simmons
lopez is ready out of the stretch first
pitch and a ground ball two-third
escobar's got it and his throat crosses
in time so lopez comes on throws one
pitch and gets the final out of the
ending but another run first and third
down here's nick ahmed
fastball goes right through rendon
that'll get walker home with the
diamondbacks first run
peralta's into third ahmed's at second
and it's six to one
runners at second and third now peyman
smith could get a hit here he could cut
that lead in half it's 6-1
so he's ready it's a full count in the
payoff pitch and that is a called third
strike a curveball freezes haven smith
struck him out looking pair of
strikeouts in the inning here's josh van
meter who's popped out and lined up
jammed him with a fastball in simmons is
out there
he had it for a moment
and then didn't
and now they throw it away
snowball fight
josh van mater snakes into second
a chance now for christian walker who's
single and scored his last time up
christian gets it by walsh at first base
van meter will come in and score and
it's six to two the rbi for walker
bay's hit can make it a 6-4 ball game
eduardo escobar has struck out twice
over two here's the 2-2 pitch
it's popped in the air into left center
field and this should be an easy play
under making the grab is upton and
canning will get that final out here in
the top of the fifth inning here is
simmons was watch scored and
grounded to third
escobar with a nice stupid third and van
meter turns it pavon smith
with the pick at first nicely done there
by the whole interior carson kelly leads
it off
out toward right center field tailing
away from trout has some carry to it a
trout will track it down at the wall
nice play by mike at the last second
reaching up and robbing kelly of extra
bases excellent play that was by trouty
on that one
and indeed cole calhoun will bound with
two on and two out here in the seventh
inning chance to get the margin to one
oh this is a big time at bat now
next pitch on calhoun he pops this one
up it's around the mound let's see who's
going to call for this when it will be
rendone and he makes the catch
one foot on the pitcher's mound and that
will end the inning walsh has had a one
for two game he has a single a sac fly
swung on and ripped and that's a diving
stop by van meter throws from his knees
and he got him at first
nice play by josh van meter to take a
hit away from jared walsh to start the
seventh inning yeah walsh hit that ball
well next batter up will be albert he's
had a pair of hits today a couple of
singles
6-2 in the seventh angel's late at the
pitch
and he throws his bat at the ball and
misses it he's a strikeout victim
yeah that'll end the ending so riley
smith goes four shutout innings here
simmons looking for his first hit today
he's hit a couple of balls down to
escobar the third baseman he's also
walked and scored
here's the next pitch that's a little
shot into left center field that's going
to drop in for a hit coming around and
scoring on that one will be ward so
simmons keeps his little hitting streak
going a four gamer there rbi hit angels
add on
two outs the diabetes down to their
final out the banner will be josh van
meter
and mater sends one out to right that's
a base hit
here comes pavon smith the rbi for josh
van meter
and it's seven to three
walker two for three two singles a
strikeout to walk
payoff
ground ball to short should do it
simmons has it
light that baby up as the angels take
the finale this afternoon